our main story this week is Scotland
Americans know it as the birthplace of
Shrek and and that accent you think you
can do but actually can't well
this coming Thursday Scotland is facing
a major decision Scotland will vote this
week on whether to leave the United
Kingdom but the first time in modern
history London could be at risk of
losing control of Scotland it could
become its own country yes it seems like
England may lose yet another country and
look I'm not saying the Sun is setting
on the British Empire let's just say the
restaurant of history is switching to
its dinner menu now now there is a lot
to explain here especially because when
most American people think about
Scottish independence they tend to
picture this
[Music]
oh yes nothing screams Scottish freedom
quite like a millionaire Australian
anti-semite on horseback is currently a
member of the United Kingdom which is
not a country it's actually a
complicated political and economic union
think of it as an okapi logic supergroup
comprised of four variously willing
members and to understand why Scotland
may want to leave you really need to
understand the history of its
relationship with England for centuries
England and Scotland remained separate
and frequently at war but in 1707 they
formed a single country Great Britain a
decision that's been controversial in
Scotland ever since oh yeah I'd say it's
still controversial given that as you
can see here we are still role-playing
with wooden swords to try and
emotionally work through it
so Scotland and England have been
involved in something of a 300 year
arranged marriage and look oh I will be
the first one to acknowledge England has
been a little bit of a dick since the
honeymoon in 1746 we actually banned the
kilts just because we knew they liked it
we chose god save the king as the UK's
national anthem a song which at one
point had a verse referencing rebellious
Scots to crush although although to be
fair we later realized that that was
wrong and replaced it with a line about
pissing on the Welsh but two and a half
years ago it was announced that Scotland
would finally get to vote on its
independence and since then there has
been a spirited campaign live our two
campaigns yes Scotland's backed by the
SNP and the Scottish greens and better
together okay for a start
better together is not a great name for
a campaign it sounds like what people
say to convince themselves to stay in a
dead marriage I'm not saying we're good
together Marion I'm saying we're better
together tax wise it's preferable to the
alternative
why are you crying Marion I'm saying
something nice
and if you think their name is
uninspiring wait until you hear their
slogan no thanks no thanks no thanks no
thanks no thanks is a violently British
way to refuse something that is just one
step away from oh I couldn't possibly
[Laughter]
what's even more interesting here is who
is helping fund these two campaigns
Harry Potter author JK Rowling wants
Scotland to stay part of the UK Raleigh
has donated 1.6 million dollars to the
better together campaign yep but that's
not really a surprise is it she famously
wrote a book where a redhead played
second fiddle to a magical Englishman I
shall have all the powers and your
brothers can die fighting my Wars come
on meanwhile meanwhile the opposing side
has received 80% of its funding from
these two people jackpots her Scottish
couples scooped a hundred and sixty-one
million pounds on the lottery making
them Europe's biggest ever winners
that's right
the pro-independence campaign is
predominantly financed by lottery
winners they're like an adorable
Scottish version of the Koch brothers so
so so let's just look at the two
arguments first the case in favor of
Scottish independence we can take
matters into Scottish hands no one
absolutely no one will run the affairs
of this country better than the people
who live and work in Scotland and to be
fair he might be right about that Scots
know how to run a country because when
they got to choose a national animal
they selected and I swear this is true a
unicorn
[Applause]
the fictional animal yeah
America's probably kicking itself for
choosing the balls eagle now on you you
could have picked a Wookiee in a top hat
or whatever the grimace is look he
looks like a magic Genie granted a wish
to Gorbachev but mark but an otter
awesome for their national flower the
Scots chose a thistle that is a plant
made out of tiny knives and a throwing
star the only flower I like is a flower
that could pierce an Englishman's throat
there are legitimate reasons for
Scotland to want to govern itself for
instance it's a predominantly liberal
country which has frequently been
governed by a conservative UK government
and seldom has that divided be more
pronounced than right now when the UK's
Prime Minister is David Cameron
Cameron's problem is there as a posh
Southern Tory he's seen in Scotland as
the personification of everything that's
wrong with England and the UK yeah I
agree with that he embodies all the
things I hate most about England and I'm
English let me prove this - this is a
picture of him as a student at Oxford
he's in tails now Cameron says
he's desperately embarrassed by that
photo which is why it pains me so much
to be showing it to you can we get a
close-up on his face because that is the
face of a man who fast forwards through
the servant parts of doubt and Abbey
just
who cares what's happening downstairs
let's just hope the soup doesn't get
cold in fact let me show you what an
David Cameron is one of the
biggest issues in the independence
debate concerns the fact that Scotland
has a surprisingly large amount of oil
but watch how David Cameron responded to
a simple parliamentary question about
who should control revenues from it a
poll last week sure that 68% of Scots
want oil revenues devolved to Scotland
does the Prime Minister agree that 68%
of Scots are there denoise
if
if you if you asked a stupid question
you get a stupid answer
[Applause]
imagine that sound for 300 years and it
gives you some sense of why Scotland may
be ready to leave okay so let's look at
the ante independence campaign now
clearly they had some serious work to do
unfortunately their attempts to win
hearts and minds involved this
controversial commercial targeted at
women featuring a Scottish mother
confused by the whole concept of
Independence who has just sent her kids
off to school best paper they do this
when they're all late nice and quiet
if you tend to think helps you clear
your head she more the last stop two
minutes
don't get me wrong I know how important
this vote is there's not much time left
for me to make a decision there's so
many hours in the day oh it's so
confusing it hunts Maori head and just a
woman you know just a pair of ovaries
and sandbags how do I possibly have the
mental capacity to pick from one of two
options totally down for a no and never
trust me with an important decision
again the crazy thing about this is that
the anti independent side actually has
some legitimate arguments to make
leaving the UK could potentially have
some serious consequences for Scotland
if they vote for independence Scots have
been warned that they risk losing the
pound as their currency yeah they could
lose the pound and that's not nothing
because if they do they need to have to
join the currently unstable euro or
revert to Scotland's old currency which
I believe was sheep and threats I'll
give you a three sheep for that nut
punch in the face that we have
why do they hate us and and also while
the pro-independence campaign has put a
great deal of emphasis on Scotland's oil
there are genuine concerns over how much
might actually be left reserves are
dwindling the Office for Budget
Responsibility expects the number of
barrels produced to decline from two
million a day in 2012 to just half a
million in 2014 and if that's true that
might be a problem because if you've
ever been there you will know that solar
power is not an option for Scotland so
those are the two sides and with the
vote just days away this thing is set to
go down to the wire this morning in
shock Brits woke up to headlines like
these don't let me be the last Queen of
Scotland last stand to keep the Union a
new poll for the UK Sunday Times
newspaper shows 51% of Scots plan to
vote YES for independence and if it
comes down to just one vote we all know
who will be called upon to break that
tie go with your gut Nessie you do Hyun
se you do you it seems it seems like
there is a real chance that Scotland may
leave and if they do just so you know
there are going to be some significant
consequences for everybody they might
also have to say cheerio to something
more symbolic the beloved Union Jack you
see the current flag which hasn't
changed in over two hundred years is a
mix between England's Cross of st.
George
Scotland's Cross of st. Andrew and
Ireland's Cross of Saint Patrick the
government could ditch the
blue-and-white cross of st. Andrews for
something that looks like this oh great
well there goes my bedspread
my shower curtain my wallpaper and my
dog
I'll believe it we can't do it he's not
just flags that are a cause for concern
there is also the small matter of this
this Scottish National Party wants to
get rid of the nuclear weapons that are
currently based in Scotland and shift
them back to England and that would be a
huge problem for the United Kingdom yeah
that would also be a huge problem for
everybody because we have nowhere to
keep them right now I mean I guess we
could disguise them as Buckingham palace
guards but people are going to notice
that after a while and Scotland wants
those weapons gone their leaders have
described them as and I quote an affront
to basic decency and this is coming from
the land of the haggis a boiled sheeps
stomach stuffed with organ meats it is
no wonder the British government is
suddenly panicking they are scrambling
to make nice with Scotland but here's
the problem when you haven't been nice
to someone for a thousand years it's
very difficult to suddenly start for
instance last week they tried raising
the Scottish flag over 10 Downing Street
watch how that went on the roof of
Downing Street on the orders of the
Prime Minister no less a moment of high
symbolism oh dear and it's not as though
everything was going swimmingly before
not even English flag poles can suddenly
start treating Scotland with the respect
it deserves
get this rag off me get it off I can't
get this blue mess off me act and in the
last ditch effort David Cameron has even
tried like a romantic hero to turn up at
Scotland's door and plead for them plead
for them not to leave I would be
heartbroken if this family of Nations
that we've put together and that we've
done such amazing things together if
this family of Nations was torn apart
that's it that's the best pleading
you've got there are only four days left
look if I've learned one thing from the
last four minutes of British romantic
comedies is that if you're trying to win
someone over you need a big romantic
gesture a kiss in the rain a kiss in the
snow turning up to someone's door with
romantic side
expressing your love for them because he
can't say it out loud because her
husband your best friend is in the next
room which is a bit tough but but
whether it is effective its effective so
with that in mind let's do this
because right now Scotland I'm just a
boy standing in front of a nation asking
it to continue tolerating me you want me
to show you what I'm willing to do to
save this relationship
here I will eat some habits there are
literally sheep lungs in my mouth let me
just wash that down with some fine
Scottish whiskey it tastes like a
delicious house fire
look at me Scotland I'm drunk on scotch
I'm trying to choke back sheep along
vomits so kiss me Scotland
what do you mean this isn't enough look
here's your national animal
[Applause]
and if that's not enough unlike the
ultimate sacrifice oh yes that's right I
will find enjoyment of my pop music
[Applause]
people
particular song
[Applause]
[Music]